draco how many
is this is this project number three or
four for you since you've been out
just four
fifth project since you got out and i
talked to you
i don't even know when that was and you
would just drop the first one and it was
and i it was like it felt like two or
three weeks after
i was like [ __ ] yeah they'll be ready
for that and then the output is
incredible
[ __ ] his version of industry [ __ ]
is is uh we know the truth like that's
draco industry [ __ ]
i mean that's it that's that's just me
knowing his rap style
to me that's how far i think it's gonna
go that's fair
like listening to his approach coming
off right am i right yeah
what did you learn um from him as far as
you know obviously you being you're
going you know you're in his shadow
you know what i'm saying um what have
you taken from him
and applied to your own you know style
and and how you record and how you write
and all that [ __ ]
other than the lady [ __ ] the fast coming
up with the crafty [ __ ]
he be coming up with [ __ ] like five
minutes like he gonna listen to a brand
we should be like young these are gonna
listen to a beat and then come back like
with a whole
like whole damn near 20 some bars just
like easy in five minutes or whatever b
he felt like listening to
draco you write him down like in your
phone or you're just off the top of the
head a minute ago
i don't be having time to really write
[ __ ] like that
sometimes i do but i'll be punching in
now though